welcome to this video playing hmm zuppa
more from Serbia I need to look at those
flags again they're irritating this
simula ok we have a willow pass
exchanged not the most exciting opening
um I'm playing usually sidelines to make
it a bit more interesting but that's not
oh it's working again let's see yeah
this is this is at least a bit different
than a normal exchange ok let's see ya
yeah well c5 is hanging and he's got
Bishop f4 coming quite interesting maybe
I need to really play Bishop d8 together
the bond yeah it's a bit ugly but his
plate yeah porn c3 you're just not what
you want to play and also bonds before
it's not necessarily what you want to
play so it's not all all great for what
there are also things in my favor let's
see this is still slightly irritating
where to put the noid unsure
93 to d5 this is probably coming
I'm aiming for the default square myself
why not it's a weekend square after all
note that i still can castle sometimes
as it is a bit similar to the Berlin hmm
you think okay I cannot castle but you
can okay yeah not sure how to play that
it looks a bit ugly with the bishop on
the 8th but this is really not nothing
terrible happening it's a very sturdy
structure hmm at long-term I always have
the bishop am maybe I can provoke him to
play a form yeah successful weakening
the p-3 p3 on so let's see I can take a
little bit ideas to take 94
yeah he has some coordination issues now
have a look at west slope going rogue c3
is 92 checker will be three nights e to
rook d3m playing c6 and of the night
moves as 92f I am so sir it's a slight
problem hey I wanted to play night see
to actually forgot to forgot that I
could have done it immediately but it's
a step possible of course yeah if a fire
frostbit spec speculating on a 4 which
is really a mistake not a serious
mistake but nevertheless not not a good
news ok what I need to do here is try to
quickly play on the D farm and activate
this Bishop possibly only five could
have gone to f6 yeah I could have really
gone to have six put a bit easier but
this is ok this is ok just thing is
having rooty aid
Group D three-hour wait if I play rock
th you can play 95 check okay then
looped III was really a bit silly on
wait I can do that where this is
actually ok 95 rook 8x8 takes d5 and
roped xp3 this should be okay check
takes on c6 i have i have this getting
the palm back
yeah route before me is Sarah coming
you came
hmm look before a king dysphonia
ok
intending Bishop to b4 and then rook a
three and four or maybe b5 Hannah maybe
beehive is quicker yeah let's let's not
waste time Jack and get the pawn going
quicker okay maybe he's trying to play
Bishop age 60
there's a page six sounds a bit of a
problem time morning check
can already proven to be one check check
check
hmm yeah you can write forfeits on time
you could've played bishop age six times
not like it's winning but I would really
have tried for example let's say let's
say let's stay here Pusha page six I
don't know oh yeah I can take him this
is what I wanted to do but yeah okay
it's we need strong threatening to win
the rook yeah it's not really not really
dangerous than it was it was rather okay
it it all came down to to this position
where it was really a bad mistake it's
not it's not the decisive one but here
he needs to be cautious and play a good
move I mean I'm in good shape but this
is giving it a bit away with this how do
you now save your material it's not so
easy maybe you can try yeah look t3c six
yeah okay we can do that of course sorry
I missed that that's so not difficult
through covering E too but still I have
a very nice square d for always
attacking the week porn a force not not
a good reply you should really just not
move the a porn at all this is not not a
real threat at the moment and the way it
was played I could have played nights
you do earlier even but this is it's not
bad yeah probably it was some yeah it
wasn't the best to to insist on or not
retreating what I should probably just
put it back and play with the next round
the extra exchange rock the eight we
should be five head size it's much
easier
alright thanks for watching